[Music]
what's up
you guys sleepy ladies and germs
sleepy why are you so sleepy i don't
know we just got done recording
uh uh the movie retrospective
yeah for seven i was like sleeping
through the whole thing almost
i was like what what yeah that was a
good movie i just ate
well so did i but you know he made he
made
uh stuffed green peppers yeah stuffed
bell peppers
stuffed bell peppers yeah man they're
really good i had to stop myself like i
ate one
and then i was like then i ate two more
little like half ones and then i had to
stop myself from eating the whole pan
they're pretty good they're delicious
they're not that unhealthy i mean it was
not healthy it's almost all vegetables
with like a little bit of meat and
cheese in there but it's mostly
vegetables right the only carb in there
was uh
the rice and there wasn't there's not
that much rice yeah it was just we were
just using like leftover rice but yeah
they were delicious i had to get rid of
all that stuff
might have some of that i got to eat
some salad later because we got like all
this veggies that are going bad
all right so what did it okay so what
ended up happening with this
normally i would have watched because
last night we had to watch the movie
that we're doing for the movie
retrospective
um which is which was long and by the
time it was over
i was kind of like well we need to watch
a new movie and then we didn't have time
and
we were like i don't even know what i
feel like watching or anything like that
so i was like oh hey
didn't we watch that one that was on
shutter the other day and did we ever
review it
never did and i'm like oh we never did i
was like oh handy so
let's just review that one i think
tonight we're gonna do
they just posted netflix just posted
that uh
history of swearing with nicolas cage so
we might like watch that tonight and
review that tomorrow because that looks
like it's going to be fun
but this one is a shutter exclusive
shutter just added it like you know
we just started getting a notification
right now that that we started our
stream
really yeah it's a little behind today
what well no it's not that
i mean it's like four minutes behind no
i only started like
less than two minutes ago so it's still
behind
but not that behind usually it's 10
seconds i think or 20 seconds i'm not
entirely sure
maybe it's just lagging a little bit um
but yeah so
we watched this probably what
three or four days ago something like
that so this is called the pale door
um came out this year i think it just
didn't come out until
august this is basically a western
but with witches yeah you know what i
mean like budget
like old school yeah and i will say no
it's directed by aaron koontz who i
think he also made scare package
which uh i'm pretty sure we did a review
on i remember liking that
uh pretty well i don't know if he's
related to dean coons maybe it's not
now it's produced by joe landsdale which
i was very excited about
but um i will say i didn't love it
wasn't bad there's only okay here here
is the thing
it had real good uh uh [ __ ] beginning
credits and end credits
i liked it no i like to have no i'm just
saying they spent money
oh i thought it sounded like a
backhanded well the beginning and ending
credits were good
[Laughter]
they were done real well they watched
the movie the rest of the movie was
good enough all right yeah it was to be
enjoyable
it only had one scene in it that blew
the movie for me and that was the
exterior daytime
scene that they had where they were out
in the middle of the damn town
you know what i mean and they were what
uh having it having a draw
remember there's a gunfight broke out
yeah like it does
because it's hd and it's in in broad
daylight
and everybody's wearing [ __ ] just
sparkling clean clothing
it looked like a bunch of larpers to me
or
yeah they should have kept the whole
thing in the dark probably yeah the rest
of it was nighttime shots it looked a
lot better
a lot more believable i think this
suffered from some of the same
issues as mohawk which was another
western horror movie
and again it was a lot of it was shot
during the day and the costumes just
looked too
modern they looked modern and too clean
it looked it looked like a costume and
not like those people's clothes yeah
like you didn't really believe that
like it wasn't lived in and it was right
you know and this had a little bit of
that
but not since most of it was at night it
yeah at night it looked a lot better in
the daytime
shots it blew it for me i was like man
this looks like
you know action cowboy shooting uh
events
you know yeah you guys don't know what
that is there's a [ __ ] shooting event
where you dress up like a cowboy
and it's just it's like larping but
you're really shooting you're shooting
and it just didn't look like the old
west um
they mostly got when you're doing period
man it's [ __ ] it
it's [ __ ] up you got to have people
that look like they're something out of
the 1800s yeah you definitely they gotta
have [ __ ] bad teeth
yeah they gotta be well like they got
some nutritional deficiencies
look well look at sergio leone's movies
yeah if you were [ __ ] up you were
gonna be in his movie everybody looked
kind of like
everybody looks kind of ugly you gotta
ugly for these period pieces and then
like it's and and
and clint eastwood learned from [ __ ]
sergio leone all clint eastwood's
[ __ ] classic
movies that he produced you know on
limited budgets most of them
you know a pill horse it was a pale
rider and [ __ ] high plains drifter
people looked [ __ ] up if if you look
there was like only a couple people in
there that looked normal
the girls usually well obviously the
girl and maybe like they can't have an
ugly lady
the rich guy in town you know what i
mean or you know what i mean or the dude
who owned
the hotel he looks normal the the
sheriff maybe he looked normal
everybody else looked like it's just a
genetic misfit
and that's what you need for the 1800s
to take you back that time and they
and all their [ __ ] clothes were just
ragged and worn and
it looked post-apocalyptic which because
it kind of was
yeah it wasn't to an extended extent it
was [ __ ] mad max
and you had to have a lot of [ __ ]
razor stubble and bat missing teeth and
yeah and you needed a lot of old people
walking around you know what i mean they
could barely walk around
skinny old man i always kind of said and
i've probably said this before
if i was given a budget um to make
a horror movie you know so if anybody
wants to give me a couple million hey
hey i'm right here i'll give you my
address and everything um
but i would not choose as much as i like
some period horror movies and there's
not enough of them
but i think the reason there's not a lot
of them because doing period pieces is
hard
yeah it's a you can't just i mean when
you're making something in the modern
day it's easy you just kind of go out
and [ __ ] everything's the way it's
supposed to be because this is when the
movie's supposed to be set
when you're you know when we were
talking about the vast of night
yesterday which was set in the 50s
and i yeah and i mentioned that they had
to go in there and spend 20 thousand
dollars taking like the three-point line
out of the [ __ ] basketball thing
because they didn't have
that back then so you had to have
somebody that knew
those little details about that kind of
[ __ ]
and you have to get everything right
because you don't want anybody to like
you don't want anything that's gonna
like take you out of the
you know of the experience out of the
immersion so i do kind of feel like if
you were going to make a horror movie
i'm not saying you need a big budget i'm
just saying you have to be really really
really careful
yeah now shooting the move this movie
mostly at night
was the right thing to do it was it yeah
it was pretty forgiving
um the opening scene there's some
interior shots
and in a victorian era house
where the it's being raided and their
kids are hiding in there it's still
to me look like a modern house that's
not the way leone would have done it
[ __ ] that house would have had bare
wood floors
no [ __ ] you know what i mean if it
had
wallpaper it would have been [ __ ]
torn up you know or
probably no wallpaper it just looked a
little too clean and too modern inside
that house
to me you didn't notice that yeah i did
i know what you're talking about like i
said this didn't really bother
me um it wasn't rickety enough it didn't
bother me as much as it did maybe when
like in mohawk wahawk was pretty bad um
and i didn't and
i didn't mind mohawk i liked this better
than mohawk yeah this is a lot better
than mohawk um
but even this movie i feel like it took
a little too long to get where it was
going because here's the thing
like i feel like the first half of it um
somebody's saying that uh is talking
about bone tomahawk is so good yes it is
yeah
and we've done a review of that actually
like a while back let's cross a movie of
course crust is going to be in it yeah
we're going to talk about
yeah bone tomahawks amazing and also um
he said dead birds
i've actually seen dead birds and i
actually liked that very much too
that is also like a western hormone i
don't know if you watched it with me or
not um but yeah
that was really good but so basically
the story behind this is you know like
the first
probably half or maybe even more than
half is
almost straight up a western because you
have the dalton gang it's two brothers
you have like kind of a brief prologue
at the beginning where
um the brothers are younger and there's
a raid and their parents get killed
and you know there's a whole older
brother got to protect the younger
brother thing and then we skip ahead
several years
and basically the older brother has
joined the
a gang like the dalton gang and he's
kind of the leader of it and it seems
like the younger brother
he's working at a saloon or something
right and so they try they pick up the
younger brother because one of their
you know gang members get shot and
they're like we're gonna do this big
train heist
so we need another person so they get
the younger brother and take him along
so they go on this train heist at night
and they it's successful they get in
there they find
you know the booty um very literally in
this case which is like a big trunk
which they think has like money or some
[ __ ] like that in it
they open it up and there's a girl in
there who's all kind of like
tied up and [ __ ] and she's basically
they're like well
there must be some reason that she's in
there you know what i mean like maybe
she's really valuable or something like
that so
and she's like hey if you um take me
back to
my home you know to my town then
then all the people there will reward
you right so
she basically takes him to this town
which they didn't find before it's like
some brigadoon [ __ ] or something like
that
and the town's all full of witches that
all work at the brothel
and uh and then it just goes on from
there it becomes more like a siege
type of movie so like i said i do like
i mean western horror is not my favorite
sub genre
um honestly like probably my favorite
sub genre of horrors probably like
haunted house movies
but um i do like these types of
genre hybrids because you know i think
it's interesting like if you can do
something interesting with it
and i also like that they use kind of
old school
witches i mean they look like hot ladies
they were you know
uh prostitutes but then when they went
full witch
they were super gross and like all gross
and monstery and witchy and stuff
so i do really like that they went the
old school witch route
every the movies were it's worth
watching it is worth watching
i feel like it was not a perfect movie i
would have deleted
the the outdoor daytime scenes or
re-shot them for night because it you
didn't need it
you didn't really need it and it kind of
blew the illusion of being a period
piece
the people the cast was a little bit too
big i think for the movie
i would have edited a couple yeah
trimmed down a few of the people because
it was hard to like follow everyone's
kind of story um well what else is i
gonna say
go ahead uh pat healey's in this i love
pat haley
but um yeah there was a lot of actors
that i recognized actually one of the
guys that was in i think was also in
mohawk as well
i would have trimmed the cast down a
little bit and then um
i would have cast people that were a
little bit more rough for looking it
didn't look
really healthy character actors yeah
you want some old dudes without any damn
teeth and [ __ ] like that or people that
look really damn
some sam elliott looking [ __ ]
you know and then you're gonna have some
people that got basically damn look like
bombs
and walking around in in [ __ ] oily
old [ __ ] leather survival [ __ ]
gear and [ __ ] you know the people the
people that don't look damn civilized
yeah you have to have some of that in
there that the people looked to me a
little bit too much
like actors or you know role players
they didn't
like i said they smile and they got
perfect teeth you know that's not
yes they're like that's not the old west
come on they didn't have like they had
dennis but all they did was pull your
[ __ ] teeth out make sure all them
teeth are damn
yellow [ __ ] orange and yellow and
[ __ ]
and kind of black a couple of them yeah
you should like that with crooked teeth
and stuff and
i think that's maybe a little too damn
beat up and dirty you know i hadn't had
a [ __ ] bath in a week you know
and that would be some commitment to
your craft right there if you actually
like
knocked some of your teeth out and
didn't bathe for a really long time
[Laughter]
bombs as extras and stuff yeah i think
a lot of them weren't yeah give them
some money just go out on the street and
be like hey you want to get away
i think they had guys in hollywood that
actually made a living
basically because they look like bombs
well that's what i'm saying i mean you
john carpenter's friend
president i mean that dude looked like a
bomb and he was in every one of
carpenter's movies
pretty much that's what i mean so you
have to have i mean if you're from the
president i'm a president
i feel like i mean i feel like
people people get on hollywood it's like
oh everyone has to be like perfect and
beautiful and everything like that
but a lot of working actors
are just regular looking or funny
looking or ugly or something like that
because they don't
if you had a movie that was entirely
full of attractive people nobody would
buy it yeah you need people that are
just regular
dead giveaway if everybody looks like a
[ __ ] star yeah exactly
yeah only the star looks like the star
because if everybody else looks like
hammered [ __ ] in the movie then the star
looks that much more beautiful because
like look how much looks how ugly
everyone else is in a really good
western to me half a damn cast is
[ __ ] unintelligible
[Laughter]
look what he said lance what the [ __ ]
you said what ledge
i remember him you should be able to get
away
this is my last round ammunition
i'm gonna take him out boy i'm gonna
take him
now you stand still
cause i'm gonna kill you
[Laughter]
and i'm gonna kill you good
and i'm gonna kill you slow
let's keep that piston
[Laughter]
check shooter
[Laughter]
that powder's wet you gotta have that
[ __ ]
grit to you all you all you need to do
now is grow your hair out real long
and like let it get all gray and then
grow a little bit of a beard and [ __ ]
and you could totally you could totally
i live that [ __ ] that's what i mean
i've already lived that [ __ ] you can
totally
yeah i'm gonna kill you
[Laughter]
you don't step you don't step in the
wrong territory
i live here not you
[Laughter]
but you gonna die here
yeah pat hatfield asked oh this is
interest this is a good question because
uh left the corpses tan
um is kind of a western too it's french
actually
yeah and that's another one i think it's
from 2018 2019 and i
will be reviewing that at some point
because uh i want to watch that as well
i only watched like the first couple
seconds and then i had to go do
something else
i was like oh that looks good that looks
promising but it's i didn't get to
finish it
so eventually we'll probably end up
watching that one too it looks kind of
[ __ ] up and
you know i heard it was like really
[ __ ] up but this one it's kind of like
if you like western horror movies i mean
obviously it's not as good as
it's not nearly as good as like bone
tomahawk or ravenous or something like
that
which is not exactly like a western
heart but it's kind of um
you know it's this is like it's like
middle of the road you know what i mean
it's not a
bad one yeah it's just it's not an
average not a great one
it's just kind of average i do feel like
it it was a little saggy i feel like
like you said i think there was
there was too many characters i feel
like they didn't really
they should have had fewer characters so
you could
get more emotionally invested in the
relationship between the brothers
because i felt like that was kind of
like the main
thrust of the story um so i feel like
they should have concentrated more on
that
um i did like that it was using like i
said like old school witches that looked
all [ __ ] gross and
everything they could or you know they
could look beautiful but they
were like really gross looking could
have been a little bit gorier i feel
like there wasn't a lot
of gore which is the witch but the
witches looked cool
yeah it did pick up in the end
it picked up it did deliver what it did
pretty much deliver it had an ending
that i didn't think was totally
satisfying
i think i would have taken it in a
slightly different direction but that
was that's on them that's what they
wanted to do
it did give you cowboys fight witches
yeah yeah it definitely did do that now
everybody's in there
what their favorite western is and
everything one of my favorite westerns
that you never hear anybody talking
about okay
head [ __ ] um [ __ ]
man what hey had bronson in it
and it had that japanese act a famous
japanese actor from [ __ ] torah
toratora i forgot what his name is oh
goddammit what is that
name in a movie was the name of the
movie it's called red sun
and it's oh i like that movie yeah it's
about some samurai they get [ __ ]
caught up in a train robbery and kind of
one of them falls in
with uh one of the train robbers to try
to [ __ ]
they were a diplomatic envoy and they're
and they're trying to um get back the
damn
imperial [ __ ] sword that was a gift i
think president lincoln wouldn't
the emperor yeah if i remember it's been
a long time since i've seen it yeah it
was this badass sword
it was a that's a really good move it's
a samurai western movie
straight out of [ __ ] straight out of
mandalorian
[ __ ] mandalorian and star wars is
basically a ripoff of that
a movie called red sun and i don't think
you can get it on blu-ray you can find
it on i think
you might never find it on blu-ray i
would think i mean
i tried to find it one time it was real
expensive like 40 bucks yeah but you can
still get it
yeah i think you can probably get it on
dvd but it's probably going to be an old
format
it might be able somebody might have it
streaming it's called red sun
check that [ __ ] out yeah i remember
seeing that on cable like
yeah i don't know how long ago that was
yeah bronson knocks it out of the park
so does that japanese
guy wish i could remember his name he
was he played
he played i think yamamoto's i think he
played admiral yamamoto
or or one of admiral yamamoto's [ __ ]
commanders but uh it's a good movie he's
a real famous japanese actor
you know it's weird i remember when we
watched tora toratora in school
isn't that funny i don't know why i
always remember that i don't even
remember what grade i was in sixth grade
seventh grade i don't remember
we watched that in the in my one of my
classes history class i guess but i
don't really remember
um but yeah so like i said this one
it's pretty good i liked it better than
mohawk
yeah and i don't you you really didn't
like mohawk i i didn't mind it like if
i'm doing like a
like a five star thing which like i said
i don't like to do that because it's so
reductive
but you know that mohawk would maybe be
two and a half and this one would maybe
be three
see this is the problem i'm gonna get on
mohawk now right
the problem with mohawk is that when
you're dealing with tom
tom has [ __ ] served in the infantry
in [ __ ] places like korea that are
[ __ ] tropical
all right and i'm from the south when
you show me
american soldiers
all right in those old 1700's uniforms
supposedly they were in the field for
[ __ ] weeks
and they don't even have any sweat on
they had tide pods back there didn't you
know that yeah their uniforms were just
[ __ ] brand spanking new not
dirty at all they're living in the field
in that one uniform with those silly
old-fashioned hats which they didn't
wear those in the field
i mean i feel like if you're going to
make a movie dress uniform
if you're going to make a movie like
that i should be able to like smell you
yeah you know what i mean from from the
other side of the screen
yeah actually little stink lines coming
off when you look at the details of like
all the colonial armies and then
the early american armies they wore
those uniforms in garrison
and they might warm to a pitch battle if
they had something
but when they were in the field doing
patrols they basically dressed
basically dressed like what indians
would wear wear a lot of buck skin
a lot of leather well yeah i mean
practicality that's the main
consideration they didn't wear the tall
[ __ ] foot long hats with the violins
you can't walk around
all white you know out in a [ __ ] out
in the [ __ ] florida everglades
yeah that would be like me walking
through the thing in like a wedding
dress and high heels for
right with the tall with the tall
[ __ ] marlboro
style [ __ ] riding boots it's just no
they didn't wear that well that was
just the cop that was stupid you know it
all came the original
the original american army was [ __ ]
rogers rangers and they were
basically basically [ __ ] white guys
and
part native american guys and they were
fighting
indian style you know
fighting the french and [ __ ] over the
beaver trade
you know and you couldn't fight like a
white man in the [ __ ]
united states that time hell no they had
to fight like an indian
they knew how to fight well yeah they'd
been here white man didn't know how to
fight that was some [ __ ] that was on
paper back in the hockey motherland
[ __ ] yeah no [ __ ] skirmishes
didn't work that's why
that's why the that's why the americans
that's why the colonial forces outlasted
the british they tried to fight that way
over here
you can't really do it you just can't it
was
all full and you spent guerrilla warfare
yeah especially you couldn't do it back
then yeah gorilla
where everything was tamed yeah
you didn't want your brightly colored
[ __ ] uniforms they [ __ ] were
camouflaged man
yeah but we can see you from like five
miles away
yeah just use those [ __ ] buckskin
jackets with a fringe on there to break
up your silhouette you just looking
vanish
yeah it was it was the old school gilly
suit
but yeah so you know this one's it's
worth checking out if you like western
horror if you're not into western
or not into westerns or not into western
world you probably won't you probably
won't like it because
like i said the first half of it at
least is basically like a western until
they get to the witch village
you know or the witch town or whatever
um you know and then there's like some
on cowboy action but um yeah so
but you know other than that it's worth
checking out that's all i'm gonna say
about it like i said uh eventually i
will get around to doing uh let the
corpses tan because i have heard a lot
about that one and shutter just added
that one probably about the same time it
added
this one so uh but like i said tonight
we'll probably watch that nicholas cage
swearing thing because i've been looking
forward to watching that because i'm
sure that's really entertaining
so we'll probably be talking about that
tomorrow
and uh so we have anything else that we
have to address oh oh oh
somebody sent us a blu-ray
of one hour photo yeah we don't know who
sent it and we don't know who sent it
yeah
but thank you whoever it was i love this
[ __ ] movie i love this movie
so i'm very very excited um we'll watch
i'll have to put this in the rotation
too for the uh
reviews it might be louie it might be
yeah i know
louie sends us a lot of movies michael
sends us a lot of movies yeah
um sophie sends us movies but i'm not
really sure because i think it just came
right from that that's a good movie that
hasn't seen that forever
i know i haven't either i think i saw
that in the theater and then i saw it
one or two times like on cable maybe
like 10 15 years ago but i haven't seen
it since then but i remember like really
really liking it
all right so we will see you guys again
tomorrow we're going to talk about
nicholas cage and some swearing
uh so thanks thanks for dropping by and
we'll see you tomorrow